lukas ricker denkt wahrscheinlich gerade
so in meinem leben alles seriös s kids
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge von die heißesten youtube
ich habe jetzt gesagt die neue folge von
es ist eigentlich noch nicht so wirklich
eine serie aber wert auf bock habt kann
ich doch eine serie daraus machen ihr
habt auf jeden fall unter dem letzten
video die heißesten youtuber mega mega
mega viele vorschläge hingeschrieben die
in diesem video verwenden sollte und
genau das machen leute die partner
gesehen unter anderem andrea kübler
lukas riga tadel und natürlich der
titelverteidiger luca ich hab dir
instagram account von diesen jungs
komplett gestoppt hat diverse bilder von
den rausgesucht lieferten wir jetzt der
website award.de und linus und übrigens
danke danke danke danke für die ganzen
merchandise bestellung es war richtig
richtig richtig geil zu sehen wie viele
leute die sachen gefeiert haben
ok ok macher von mit andrea an waren wir
uns jetzt einfach mal ein foto von
andreas punkt und schau mal was der hier
so haushalt ich bin gespannt andré
könnte echt abgrasen okay ist schon mal
nicht schlecht von anfang ist da nicht
von anfang ist echt nicht schlecht luca
der bisherige titelverteidiger bei
dieser aussage der titelverteidiger hat
auf jeden fall beim ersten video nun eis
geholt wir euch gleich neue renato ist
nur wenn andrea team mit stunning schon
starten kann und dann ebenfalls eine
steigerung hinlegt wie luca damals dann
wird er auf jeden fall der neue gold und
deutet noch mal zur klarstellung ich
vertrete nach wie vor keines falls die
ansicht dass das aussehen die wichtigste
eigenschaft des menschen ist es ist bei
dem video einfach nur so ist es halt
wird sich meine bilder von youtube und
jagt die durch diese webseite es kommt
etwas witziges raus man reagiert h
das heißt nicht dass ich persönlich
denke oder euch vermitteln will dass
jeder der nicht gott leid bekommt auf
dieser seite ein absolutes stoffes da
will ich nämlich auch nach loch ja aber
soviel dazu andre the giant räumt mit
seinem ersten bild stunning ab überall
etwas nicht sagt bild immer zwei von
andre 3000 bisher aufgefallen wie er
älter geworden ist so oft im letzten
bild noch 27 jahre jetzt 30 jahre
nächstes bild dann vielleicht eine
andere auf das gleiche schicksal wie ich
dass er immer noch da hinkriegt
das ist
es ist nicht leicht leute es ist
wirklich nicht leicht schon einfach nur
meiner familie zeigen dass ich auf
gotland bekommt punkt euro
schaffst du gestattet
okay heute letzte chance für andere von
fm nach auszustechen ich habe ein
richtig gutes bild von dem rausgesucht
hier das gefällt mir persönlich auch
sehr gut und jetzt einfach so wie mir
andere stehen das zusammen durch
könntest du glücklich zusammen tun
das schaffen wir zu sagen es ist
verdammt noch mal nicht leicht das
darlehen zu bekommen bei höhepunkt
dieser verdammten web stunning die
grafik schreibt direkt in bist ein
verdammter bastard als bewertung
zwischen haut und gott lag einfach du
bist ein verdammter bastard es wäre
ungefähr so genau dass gleich von der
aussage ja okay leute andré räumt
dreimal stunning ab und werden bemerkt
dass beim alter sich auch sehr verändert
hat und zwar von 27 auf 30
und dann ist er wieder sieben jahre
jünger geworden jetzt 23 ich würde sagen
leute als nächstes lassen wir gegen den
amtierenden champion luca lukas liga
antreten
den young alter ist es schon kommen
leute alle lukas rieder fans werden
dieses videos so zerstören wenn nicht
mindestens zweimal goldlack bekommt ja
gesehen wie das bei max damals war mit
dem die kleinen beef angefangen hat
komplett eskaliert jetzt bekommt er hier
nur ok ich muss an dieser stelle sagen
leute es ist nicht mein urteil
okay das von herold.at nicht meine
schuld ok lukas kein leichter start
gesichter der sich ihr kann 24 jahre
könnte passen 17 s oder sonne aber so
vom alter her ungefähr pipapo in haan
her leute
foto nummer 2 lukas rieder er hat
richtig einen mitbekommen gerade eben
alter lukas ricker denkt wahrscheinlich
gerade so das ist richtig krass
eigentlich ich würde jetzt persönlich
nicht sagen auch wenn ich nicht ein
junger musicalstars interessiert bin
dass lukas rieder als wie mega agb oder
so aber hat es halt auf haut punkt euro
eigentlich gar nicht so viel davor aber
ok bekommen oder nice bekommen ich will
so viele displays alle look austria fan
girls und fanboys dislike puncto geht
auf die seite lasst uns lag das kann man
auf jeden fall machen die haben dislike
button macht sich hier dankeschön okay
leute weltnummer 3 lukas riga lukas kaum
scheint günstig
müsste was leute es war einfach nicht
lukas tag wohl einfach nicht die
performance hier auf haut und deswegen
zwischen wie jetzt zu unserem bisherigen
titelverteidiger ich hab mal zwei bilder
von scheiße drauf gesucht
hilfe also ob als ob als ob das kann
eigentlich gar nicht sein was luca der
macht mit seinen bildern ein bisschen
euch was der macht mit seinen bildern
locker bevor irgendwas auch ins programm
hochlädt lässt er erst mal alle
möglichen zehn verschiedenen möglichen
bilder die auf machen könnte auf hort
punkt durchlaufen und nimmt nur das was
gott lag bekommt anders kann man sich
das nicht erklären der bau ist so
abgrasen hier aber wir haben noch ein
bild von luca werden noch das bild hier
das bild habe ich sogar selbst
aufgenommen als blut zwar okay
die menschheit ist beruhigt langlitz
holt auch mal nicht gott leiter bei
seinem ersten bild im ersten die
heißesten tour video hat er ja auch so
ein bisschen bewertung geholt jetzt auch
wieder hort ist okay alter passt auf
jeden fall ist er was leute um luke
herauszufordern in lucka von seinem
thron zu stoßen brauchen wir eine
absolute youtube legende eine person die
fans zum kreischen prinzip kein zweiter
die rede ist selbstverständlich fahren
okay wir steigen erst mal leicht ein
paddel hat auch nicht so viele frontale
gesichtsbild aufgezogen
deswegen mit zahnbürste hot und 18 so
wird das auf jeden fall hatten wir
setzen unsere ganze hoffnung dich du
bist der auserwählten tyrann lud den
hauptpunkt iran zu stürzen
ich finde so lust leute wieder so eine
scheiße oder drüber aber jetzt sei das
bild von halle statt
aber man muss auch sagen erst gar nicht
so getroffen auf dem weg hier finde ich
ehrlich gesagt wieso aber leute es gibt
noch hoffnung ich hatte gerade eben so
ein bild von tango aber so ein halbes
gesicht drauf hat rein die seite einfach
sein gesicht erkannt deswegen musst du
noch als raussuchen und ich habe es
gefunden nicht von instagram sondern aus
den etwas älteren zeiten sehr gute
ausstrahlung auf dem bild meiner meinung
nach sollte eigentlich klappen die quali
ist nicht so top vielleicht haut hin
wie sollen wir gegen luca vorgehen leute
wie habt ihr die werte schaffen könnte
also zusammengefasst heute hat es nicht
geschafft in hohhot punkt ein tyrann
luca vom thron zu stürzen
wir sind weiterhin auf der suche nach
einer lösung die müssen lud vom thron
stossen wenn ihr irgendwie diabetes sein
könnte der blues vom hort punkten stößt
dann schreibt man die kommentare das
gern bewerten